Speaker 1: The other bizarre item that I want
to talk about here is Jorge Santos again,
sat down with Oann in a wide ranging interview,
very candid, exclusive interview with One America
News. And he's not backing down. He apologizes
out of one side of his mouth and then says that
he's a lot of people are creating a fake narrative
that he faked his way to Congress or a narrative
that he faked his way there, ignoring all of
the lies. And he's taking issue with it. He's
acting like it's unfair how he's being treated
differently than any other member of Congress.
And then finally, a clip that he's going to
go ahead, an extra step now and double check
and cross-reference everything as though he
needs to do that with the details of his own
life. It's all a bit much. Watch this first clip.
Speaker 4: The business of politics is littered
at the highest levels with deceit,
mistruth, corruption, of course. And
this is kind of the time that you're now
entering politics. With that climate in mind,
I guess, where do you want to start? And
your is your story, your upbringing maybe?
Speaker 5: Well, Caitlyn, look, I come from humble
beginnings. I've always said that I grew up in
abject poverty in Jackson Heights, in Queens, New
York City. People like me aren't supposed to do
big things in life. And when we do, it disrupts
the system. And I know that a lot of people want
to create this narrative that I. I faked my way
to Congress, which is absolutely, categorically
false. I've worked hard. I've built ground up a
career through experience and through knowledge
and through self education. And, you know, I think
it's amazing that I have to sit here and be spoken
down to on a regular basis yet again by the media.
Speaker 1: Is George Santos really does he have
the gall and the temerity and the boldness to
to try to play this off as the system coming
down on him because he's the poor, lowly,
poor kid who isn't supposed to make it?
That the all the odds were stacked against me.
Growing up poor in abject poverty doesn't
mean that you makes you a liar. Take it from
me. I grew up exceedingly poor on welfare,
free lunch, all the works, the food stamps.
It doesn't make you a liar. And here, watch
this. Mr.. I've made atonement. I've made
apologies. I'm very sorry. I shouldn't have done
what I did. Here he is whining about the unfair
treatment that he's undergoing right now.
Speaker 5: Now angry. That's maybe you
can say that I'm passionate about all of
this, but anger is just not something you,
I would think is appropriate to describe me.
Speaker 4: What emotions do you feel right now?
Speaker 5: You know, sad, Sad that I've I
put myself in this predicament and and and
I own up to it. But I'm sad that the media has
decided now to target my family. The media has
decided to target and harass my friends, anybody
around me. I signed up for this job, Caitlin. I
signed up for this. Not my my sister. With my
five year old autistic niece or not my husband
at home with our dogs. They didn't sign up.
Speaker 4: But, you know, you know, putting
herself in anyone that puts themselves in the
spotlight, they know what baggage that comes with.
Speaker 5: I have yet to see this be done to
other members of Congress, his family, from the
death threats to the media, harassment pounding
down the door, leaving passive aggressive notes,
all things I'd be glad to share with you. And
if you can air this during this, I'll share you
passive aggressive, threatening notes.
Speaker 1: A threatening note is not
passive aggressive. It's aggressive.
It's threatening. It's also a crime.
So if you have evidence of journalist threatening,
you go to the authorities. It is a federal crime
to threaten the life or threaten a sitting member
of Congress. Get Do the good hard work. George
Santos. The media is not targeting you and you're
not being unfairly treated. You think you're the
only member of. I don't believe you're getting
death threats, but do you think you're the only
member of have you listened to. To Eric Swalwell
and the voicemails he releases on his Twitter?
Cry me a river. You've created the media frenzy.
You should be pleased as punch at what has taken
place. So enough. We get it. Follow me on social
media if you'd like to leave me threatening and
passive aggressive notes, I'm at dallimore
on Twitter, Instagram and TikTok. You can
find me here on YouTube. Dallimore Daily
is the show that I host daily Dallimore.
See how it works. I also co-host a podcast
with Britney Paige called I Doubt It that you
can find that Daniel Morcombe or anywhere that
you find podcasts. I'd love to see you there.